SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for coming here and for
your interest in this talk.
As announced via
e-mail, today we
have as guest at Google Mr. Phil
Zimmermann, the creator of PGP
and co-creator of Silent
Circle and Silent Phone.
Hi, Phil.
Welcome to Google.
How are you?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: I'm good.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: How we
got Phil to Google
was that Google gave him an
award for his contribution
to security, and
recently, as he's involved
with researching
communication security.
And we have the end to
end encryption of WhatsApp
and the recently announced
Google products in this area.
He was very kind
to accept an offer
to have a talk about his
recent research in this area.
And I'll let him present
more of his talk.
Just so you know, there
are people in this room.
There are people watching
the transmission live.
And we'll have
questions from the room
as well as in [INAUDIBLE]
and are prepared.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: OK.
SPEAKER 1: And ask at
the end of the talk.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
Well, I would assume
there's not too
many in California
because it's too early.
SPEAKER 1: You
would be surprised.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Well, you know,
normally, for most audiences,
I ask for a show of hands
for people who are engineers.
[LAUGHTER]
When I look at
this audience here,
I absolutely do not
have to ask this.
The visual signature
is so distinct that--
[LAUGHTER]
--that there is
absolutely no ambiguity.
In fact, I'm not sure that
there is a single non-engineer
in the room.
In fact, actually it's
even at this level
of pharmaceutical purity
of engineer density,
it's to the point where
I can sort of gauge
the skill level of software
engineers by appearance.
You know?
So all right, so this is the
most pure sample of engineers
I've spoken to in
many, many years.
So I guess I can be as
geeky as I want to be.
So well, I guess I'm best known
for my work thousands of years
ago for developing the PGP.
But that was a
very long time ago.
For the past more
than a decade, I've
been focusing all on Secure
VoIP, and more recently
on secure instant messaging.
But secure VoIP is far more
interesting than secure e-mail.
I had to do secure e-mail first.
Because in the 1990s,
nobody had broadband.
And without
broadband, there's not
much of a market for secure
VoIP because there's not
much of a market for VoIP.
So I had to wait.
And I had to do
secure e-mail first.
So even though I
got better known
for my work in secure e-mail,
what I actually wanted to do
was secure VoIP.
So I just had to wait for
the enabling technologies
to come into play.
So for the past decade--
for more than a decade--
I've been working
100% on secure VoIP.
The first time I did this
was 1995 with PGP Phone.
But at that time, I
was just using a modem
to talk to another modem.
So it was two PCs talking
through dial up modems.
And it wasn't even
internet protocol.
It was just modem to modem.
It was kind of like the STU-III
or the other secure telephone
devices that existed at the type
that used only the phone lines.
But anyway, so now that we have
these enabling technologies
of broadband and also VoIP
standards like the SIP
standard in and RTP,
I've been doing that.
I started out with Zfone
about 10 years ago.
And today, I have a
product called Silent Phone
from Silent Circle.
That's the company that I
started about four and a half
years ago.
But we didn't get a
huge network effect.
Because we pursued
a different business
model where we charged
for our product.
And I kind of regret that now.
Because I can see
that just recently,
WhatsApp got a
billion users with end
to end encryption immediately.
Because I mean, they ramped
up the network effect.
And then suddenly,
turned on encryption
when they reached
a billion users.
So I thought that was
a pretty effective way
to bring a billion users
into secure communications.
But anyway, what
I'd like to talk
with you about today
is how do you protect
your users from yourself?
If you're a company
like Apple and you
have products that encrypt
things like the encryption
that iPhones have,
and the FBI comes in
asks you to defeat
your own encryption,
what can you do to be
able to say to them,
well sorry, I can't do that?
Well, Tim Cook had to
fight them in court.
But wouldn't it be
easier if he could just
say, well, we just don't
have the means of doing that.
And that would be easier
if he could do that.
And I suspect that
Apple is now working
on trying to improve their
security to the point
where the next time someone asks
them to do that, they can say,
sorry, no can do.
And I think that
it would be helpful
if all the big companies
that make products that
do encryption could do that
also like Google, like Facebook,
like any other large
scale company that
has a billion users.
We have a society of
pervasive surveillance.
We always knew that.
I mean, security
people knew that.
But we didn't know it was
quite as breathtakingly
sweeping in its scope until
the Snowden revelations.
And now, since the
Snowden revelations,
everybody's been trying
to up their game.
Standards bodies are
trying to up their game.
The IETF is trying to
deprecate old security, all
the old crypto suites,
trying to make standards
for a world of
pervasive surveillance,
how to defend
yourself against that.
NIST is trying to recover
from the humiliation they
had to endure because of the
random number generator that
was handed to them by NSA-- the
not-so-random number generator.
And you know, I mean NIST crypto
standards are really very good.
If you sit down and read their
SP 800 series of publications,
they're just
absolutely excellent.
You just had that one
embarrassing problem.
And they've gotten rid of it.
But everybody's trying
to make improvements.
And Apple's been
making improvements.
Google started
encrypting their links
between their data centers.
I'm absolutely horrified that
you guys weren't doing that
already.
What were you thinking
that you didn't do that?
So you should be embarrassed
along with everyone else,
right?
But you know, when I first
started working on secure VoIP,
I just assumed that you cannot
trust the phone company.
And so I did this protocol that
negotiates its keys end to end
and absolutely does not
trust the phone company.
And when I say
the phone company,
I mean the servers, the
service provider, the servers.
The servers are not involved in
the cryptographic negotiation.
Now, the way I do it is I do
an ephemeral Diffie Hellman
exchange.
And then I derive something to
display on the screen that's
derived from the session key.
And then I have the
two parties compare
what they see on the screen
to see if it matches.
If it matches, the
session keys are the same.
If the session
keys are the same,
then that means there
is no man in the middle.
That's a good thing.
All the complexities of PKI, all
that work that we put into PKI
is to prevent a man
in the middle attack.
And yet, PKI has
done very poorly
at this over the
past like 20 years.
PKI has just had a
bad track record.
The most spectacular
failure was--
there's been a number of
spectacular failures--
but the most
spectacular of them was
the one with the
Iranian hackers hacking
into a Dutch
certificate authority
and stealing their
signing key that could
create credentials for anyone.
And the public key for
that certificate authority
was baked into
everyone's browsers.
And the hacker that did that
forged hundreds of certificates
for Gmail, for Yahoo!
Mail, for Facebook, for
government agencies,
and handed off all
these credentials
to the Iranian government who
then used them to perform man
in the middle attacks
on Iranian dissidents
and arrested so many of
them and put them in prison.
So if you wanted to try to
write just a fictional novel
of the absolute worst case
of what is the theoretically
worst possible failure of a
public key infrastructure,
that would have to be it.
So there's been a lot of effort
to try to reform PKI, centrally
manage PKI.
For example, certificate.
Transparency seems to
be a big improvement.
But it still depends on
the certificate authority
not becoming evil.
It does protect against
someone stealing the keys
and making unauthorized
certificates.
But what if they're
authorized certificates
that are just lying?
What if governments could compel
certificate authorities to lie?
What can you do to
reduce the dependency
on certificate authorities?
Well, what I did with
my protocol, ZRTP,
was to make it so it just
doesn't use a PKI at all.
And this thing about displaying
a hash of the session key
will work for a
VoIP application.
Because you're already
speaking-- it's a human speech
encryption product, right?
So you're talking to
another human being.
So why not use the humans,
drag the human brain
into the protocol,
100 trillion synapses
dragged into the protocol.
Instead of relying on just
a little ARM processor,
you've got 100 trillion
synapses on each end
that participate
in a calculation
by listening to the
other person tell you
what's displayed on the screen.
We don't have to do
a fingerprint compare
like I'm sure that many of
you have seen PGP key signing
parties.
Remember what I said
about theoretical limits
of geekiness?
The frontier of geekiness can
be found at PGP key signing
parties.
It's kind of right
up there, you know?
But you can't get people to
compare full size fingerprints
on a phone call.
Nobody would ever do it.
So I made it so that the amount
of material you have to compare
is just two bytes.
And I use the PGP word list.
The PGP fingerprints can
be displayed in hexadecimal
or using the word list.
And I used that same word
list for displaying on Zfone
originally, and now-- actually,
PGP Phone did it, and then
Zfone, and now Silent Phone.
And it's part of
the ZRTP standard.
So you compare two words.
And if they match, you're good.
And the protocol makes
it possible to do this
by allowing you to use a short
truncated hash because it
does hash commitment
in the protocol.
Instead of just truncating
the hash of the session keys,
it makes it so that
it's possible to use
a truncated hash without
a birthday attack
by a highly resourceful
attacker that
could sit there and perform a
lot of parallel calculations
to try to force a match of
the first 16 bits of the hash.
You put him in a position
where he only gets one guess.
He can only do one.
He cant' do trial calculations.
You make it so that when you
send the public component
of the Diffie
Hellman calculation,
you don't send it right away.
You send a hash of it first.
And then you get the
other party to send
his public component of the
Diffie Hellman calculation
after you get that.
Then you finally reveal your
public component, the one
that you hashed first.
He gets it, compares it with
the hash, and caches it again.
If it matches, then he uses it.
And by doing it that
way, you put the guy
in the middle in a
position where he can't
do a whole lot of guesses.
He can't do a bunch of trial
Diffie Hellman calculations.
He only gets one guess.
And so because of that, if
you display a 16-bit hash,
he has only one chance in
65,000 of getting it right.
He has only one chance of
65,000 of not being detected.
And that's a powerful
disincentive.
He's never going to
even try the attack
if his odds of getting it
undetected are so pessimistic.
So that's the foundation
on which ZRTP rests.
That plus, we make
it so that you don't
have to compare every time.
Because we have this
other component.
We have key continuity.
At the end of every session, you
destroy all the key material,
which is great for
forward secrecy.
But before we destroy it,
we take the session key
and hash it one more time.
We run it through a key
derivation function.
And we store that in
a cache for next time.
And the next time you call
the same person again,
it does a fresh
Diffie Hellman just
like you did on the first call
with fresh random key material.
And when you derive
the new session key,
you are mixing together
the Diffie Hellman result
with the previous cache material
from the previous call that you
made to the same person.
And that way, if there was no
man in the middle on the first
call, there cannot be a man in
the middle on the second call
or the third because
you do this every time.
At the end of every
call, you hash it again,
your destroy all the
original material,
but you hash it and
store the hash-- which
because these hashes
are not invertible,
it's OK to do that-- and then
you use it the next time.
So this is a form
of key continuity.
That means you only have to do
this little ritual of comparing
the fingerprint--
not the fingerprint,
the short authentication
string-- you only
have to do that one time
for each person you talk to.
After you've done that, you
have this key continuity going.
So in most cases where
an attacker wants
to do a man in
the middle attack,
he's not going to do it
on the first session.
He probably doesn't
take an interest
in wiretapping you until later.
By then, it's too late.
You've already got this
key continuity chain going.
Every call, you refresh
the material in the cache.
And you do it again
on the next one.
So the key continuity and the
short authentication string
which is enabled by
this hash commitment
during the Diffie Hellman
is a good combination
to make it possible
to do ephemeral Diffie
Hellman without relying on
a public key infrastructure
with certificate authorities.
You don't need
persistent key material.
It's not even persistent
even in the cache
because it's changed every time.
Now, everybody in this
room has used SSH.
I don't have to ask
for a show of hands
for the aforementioned visual
signature of what engineers
look like, right?
And so SSH also
has key continuity.
Because when you talk to a
server, you get a public key.
You store it in
your local cache.
And you use it next time when
you talk to the same server.
It tells you again
this public key.
You compare, see if
it's the same one.
That's key continuity.
But that's a different
kind of key continuity.
That's for a persistent
public key that never changes.
That means that you have
to protect your private key
over a long term.
And if anybody ever
steals your private key,
they can impersonate
you forever.
Or if anybody steals the
private key of the server,
they can impersonate the server.
And it's not that easy to
protect the private key
on a server.
Because the server is up 24/7.
And there's no human there.
And so the private key has to
be accessible all the time.
And that means that anybody
can get into the server
and escalate their privileges.
They can get to
that private key.
So the way I do key
continuity is a bit different
in that it's always ephemeral.
It's less brittle.
And it also has
another property,
which I didn't think was so
important when I designed it.
But it's starting to
look more important.
And that is people are
starting to get concerned
about the post-quantum
environment for cryptography.
Now, I think it's going to
be a long time before we
have to worry about
quantum computers.
But you know, NSA is
saying that maybe we
should start worrying now.
And so NIST has put out a
document saying everybody--
they're trying to
solicit suggestions
for public key algorithms that
can resist quantum computers.
And so it just so
happens that ZRTP already
had resisted quantum
computers in most scenarios.
Because even though
I'm not using
any new exotic public
key algorithms, I'm just
using elliptic curve
Diffie Hellman,
which is not resistant
to Shor's algorithm that
would be available to
a quantum computer,
it's still difficult for-- see,
the only reason to worry today
about quantum computers
is because if you have
a very powerful opponent who
records your traffic today
and archives it for 50 years,
and then 50 years in the future
uses quantum computers to
retroactively figure out--
breaks the traffic by
using Shor's algorithm
to break your public
key calculations,
I mean, that is something that
if you think that someday there
will be quantum computers,
then you've got to think,
if I want to protect
the traffic today
from a future retroactive
examination of my traffic,
then what I've done
with ZRTP is actually
resistant to that
kind of attack.
Because if your opponent misses
a single session of a ZRTP
exchange, then
he's going to miss
that cache key material that's
resulted from that session.
And then every
session after that
will be unable to break
even with quantum computers.
Because quantum
computers, if we are
assuming that it's
Shor's algorithm
which can break public key
algorithms in polynomial time,
then they can't break
symmetric algorithms.
They can't break the AES for
example or hash functions.
And so the cache key material
is symmetric key material.
So you mix it in and use it.
And you get to key continuity.
So it would be immune
if your opponent
misses a single session.
So even those ZRTP
doesn't use any
of these advanced
public key algorithms
like algorithms based on
lattices or coding theory,
it's still good because
of the key continuity,
assuming that your opponent
misses one session.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Sure.
But they can't do it
50 years from now.
Because the computer
doesn't exist anymore.
And you might be dead by then.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
They could do it now.
But they don't have
quantum computers now.
AUDIENCE: You said
that you, I mean,
[INAUDIBLE] identify check
the hash the first time.
I was under the assumption
that the key is--
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
Yeah, but even if they
extract-- if they break
into your computer
and extract the material,
even if they break in today
and extract the
cached material, it's
only good for the next session.
And it gets
replenished every time.
So if they're going to exploit
the material that they stole,
they have to exploit
it on the next session.
If they miss that one
opportunity, too bad.
They're going to have
to steal it again.
So it's always getting changed.
It's operationally quite
a challenge for them.
So all in all, ZRTP covers a
lot of the attack scenarios.
And it does it without relying
on public key infrastructure
or centrally managed
certificate authorities.
And so if you're worried
about building-- like you
guys recently announced a couple
of new products-- Allo and Duo,
which do end to end encryption
both for text messages
and for voice and video.
And that's great.
But if they rely on a protocol
to negotiate the session key,
that might be subject
to attack at the server.
For example, if you were using
WebRTC which relies on DTLS,
that relies on long term
persistent public keys
that the server provides.
If that could be compromised,
possibly with the cooperation
of the server, which could
be coerced-- remember,
we're talking about
the coercion scenario
where Google or
Apple or whoever's
running the service
could be coerced--
you have to consider your own
company as part of the threat
model.
But if you use protocol
that's designed to not trust
the service provider
like ZRTP, then you're
immune to the service
becoming evil.
I mean, the service
promised not to be evil
when this company
was founded, right?
But it's a tough
promise to live up
to when somebody comes in
with a national security
letter or a court order.
So you have to take into account
that even if the service does
something bad, it
would be helpful
if you had a protocol that is
immune to that kind of a threat
model that includes
your own company.
SPEAKER 1: Phil, can you
already take some questions?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
Yeah, yeah sure.
Let's do that.
SPEAKER 1: So let's take
one from the room first.
And I have one related
to exactly your latest
point from online.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Should be on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So you mentioned that the
ZRTP protocol prevents
the man in the middle attack.
But if you don't have any
permanent key material
on the end points, how can--
so if I call you on ZRTP,
how do I know that I'm talking
to you and not to a look-alike?
So this is mostly a problem
from e-mail and text protocol.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: This
is not for e-mail.
This is just for voice.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: It's
designed for a voice
product like voice telephony.
AUDIENCE: So you're
assuming that they
would recognize your voice
on the phone, for instance?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: I mean,
I thought about somebody
imitating your voice.
I call it the Rich Little
attack because there
was a famous voice impressionist
named Rich Little back
in the 1970s.
And the man of
1,000 voices, right?
But it's not enough to
simply imitate your voice.
See, if you see the short
authentication stream,
it says ski lift Capricorn.
And so you could talk
to the other person.
You'd say, oh, you
remember that time we
went skiing in Colorado,
and we rode on a ski lift?
Remember that?
You know?
And you can work it
into the conversation
if it becomes part
of the threat model.
Like if somebody finds that
there's an attack like this,
they're going to
post it on Slashdot.
You know?
Everybody's going to
know that, OK, somebody's
trying to screw around.
They're trying to imitate
voices to break this.
And so everybody
would be more careful.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there's
also the scenario
where you'd talk to
someone you don't know yet,
like they're calling for
the first time to Google
to request their tech support.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Then how do you
know you actually reach them?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
Yeah, well, I guess
it could be done in that case.
But still, even
there, they would
have to imitate the voice
of the entire session.
Because the voice
that's used to recite
the words has got to be the same
voice that you're talking to
for the rest of the session.
AUDIENCE: But assuming
that you don't
no the voice of
the person you're
calling for the first time.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah,
they can do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Right.
But if you want to use it
in other scenarios, where
for most people, they want
to talk to somebody that they
know, they want to talk to--
I mean, look, if you're going
to have a confidential
conversation, in most cases,
you'd know the person.
Because if you don't
know them, you're
less likely to be talking
about something confidential.
SPEAKER 1: I think-- can
you pass it behind you?
I'll first ask the
question that I got online.
And then it's you.
So I'm just going
to read it out.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: The
question is as follows.
What are the main
security issues
of replacing centralized
call set up in user database
like currently in
Duo with [INAUDIBLE]
decentralized
system, for example,
the machinery used by ring.cx?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Used by what?
SPEAKER 1: It's ring.cx.
It's a company that
provides a framework
for doing decentralized call
setup and user database.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Well, you need
to have a centralized server
for routing the calls.
You have to have
something running
SIP or some other protocol
to setup the call,
do the signaling
part of the call.
But it doesn't
have to be part of
the cryptographic negotiation.
It could route the messages
that are used to negotiate
the crypto part of it.
But it doesn't have to be a
participant getting access
to key material.
And that's the difference.
I mean, you want to make it
so that the servers are not
in possession of
private key material.
If you can just achieve
that one objective,
then it doesn't matter that
the servers are setting up
the call.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of research
into security protocol
and application shows that
usually the weakest link is
the end user not understanding
the security guarantees
and not using the
software properly.
So you know, with
a secure phone,
they won't bother reading the
words or they'll flub it up.
Or even more importantly,
you said that we
don't rely on a central server.
But even if your product
is completely secure,
there is still automatic
updates and stuff like that.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Oh sure.
AUDIENCE: So say
Google implemented
a completely secure NGN server.
Hey can just push--
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --an update that
bypasses it on the [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Well, yeah.
Pushing updates, that's a major
part of the attack surface.
In fact, actually,
Apple is even worse.
Because Apple only allows
the Apple Store to be the one
that gives you these updates.
Most Apple users don't have
the ability to load an app.
Unless they're developers,
they could do it that way.
But if they're not, then
the only game in town
is the App Store.
Google Play is not the only
way to get an app on Android.
But it's the one
that most people use.
So at least you've got some
other way to get it on there.
But that's only for
the dedicated fanatics.
So if the App Store or
the Google Play Store
can be attacked, perhaps even
without the knowledge of Google
or Apple, then
they could somehow
make it deliver updates
that are specially
designed for the attacker.
But you have to
put a lot of work
into the Google Play Store and
the App Store to prevent that.
It's also getting worse in
that we're now seeing efforts
to have just-in-time resolution
of the binaries, which
makes it hard to sign
the binaries in advance
because there's different
versions of the execution
environment that the
binaries can be configured
for on a phone by phone basis,
a customer by customer basis.
And that makes it even harder
to do digital signatures on it.
So that's something that
needs a lot more work.
AUDIENCE: Obviously, there
is a double bind here.
Because if we don't
do any updates,
then users are running outdated
software, which will eventually
have discovered security holes.
And you're back to the same end
user exploitability problem.
If you look in real life,
almost always the compromises
are based on exploits on
the end user software.
Even with the iPhone case, the
FBI ended up not needing it
because they found a
company that will exploit
some kind of end user security.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: The fact is
that the highly resourceful
intel agencies around
the world-- the NSA
being the most powerful--
have ways of getting
into individual phones.
If they really, really want
to get into your phone,
they will get in.
When you put 30,000
engineers and scientists
and mathematicians coming
to work every single day,
spending all day
long, day in and day
out for years and years
talking to their very
intelligent colleagues
about how we're
going to make this better,
they'll find a way in.
I mean, the FBI did not
ask for any help from NSA
because they wanted to
make a point in court.
They wanted to set
a legal precedent.
They could have gotten in
with help from the NSA.
As it stands, they went
out to a private vendor.
But you know, you've got to at
least get a start somewhere.
You've got to start
with protocols
that are immune to bad
behavior from the server that's
providing the service.
And we also have to work on
the distribution of updates.
But one of the obstacles
to making this kind of push
to reduce the dependency
on the server being good
is that you have to have the
attitude that the server will
not always be good.
Just because it's
your company's server,
you've got to stop
trusting your company.
I mean, if the government
came into my company
with a court order
and said, give us
everything you
have on this user,
we don't want to go to jail.
We would have to do
whatever we can to give them
something for that user.
But we've architected
things so that we
don't have much to give them
just cybertext, maybe credit
card information, except we
use an external processor.
So they'd have to go there.
So you've got to have
the attitude that-- Apple
failed to have that attitude.
They did not take themselves
as part of the threat model.
But now they do.
Now they understand.
They've been through
that experience.
Now they understand
that they themselves
are part of the threat model.
And so their
engineers, I am sure,
are working now to include
themselves in the threat model
and to try to make it so that
the next time after they make
these improvements,
they'll cut themselves out
of the threat model.
And you guys have
to do the same.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Now it's on.
OK.
So if each session key derives
from the previous session key,
that kind of requires every end
user to use a single device.
Otherwise--
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
No, every device--
AUDIENCE: --they'll have
to synchronize the session
keys between their smartphones.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
No, each device--
it's a device to
device protocol.
It doesn't care how
many devices you have.
If I call from my
device to your device,
and then tomorrow I'm
talking to your other device,
then we'll do it again.
You will have to do the
verbal comparison twice.
AUDIENCE: So that means
that one way to attack
would be to physically
steal somebody's phone
so that they would
have to re-authenticate
with the other user
with a new smartphone.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: That's right.
But you know, you could tell
them that you lost your phone.
And now you have another one.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Can you hear me?
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I can hear myself.
So that's probably good.
So for that thing,
there's OMEMO.
It lets you sync
keys across devices.
And basically, one device can
say, yes, this other device
is trustworthy as well.
It's a really good protocol.
Maybe ZRTP should
incorporate that.
Anyway, thank you
for being here.
I'm a customer of yours.
I dropped the phone already
as you can probably tell.
And I wanted to ask, why
the change in strategy?
Silent Phone 1 did not
come with Google Play.
And Silent Phone 2
came with Google Play.
I actually had to return
that phone for that reason.
And what changed about
the whole product strategy
that had happened at the time?
If you know, maybe you don't.
I don't know.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Well,
a lot of these decisions
were made by non-engineers.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: We're also
familiar with this problem.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Anyway, thanks.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: If they'd
listen to the engineers
from the start, we'd been
in better shape with that.
Just a little bit of advice
when you start a company,
it's a good idea to try to get
as many engineers as possible
involved in the decision making.
[LAUGHTER]
Or as few-- let me rephrase
it-- as few non-engineers as
possible with decision making.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
being here today.
If I may, I'd like to
widen the scope a little.
So we talked a lot about
protecting the content
of your communication.
We talked a lot about
protecting the content
of your communication to
cope with mass surveillance.
Another thing is--
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: The metadata.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah,
and traffic analysis.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Discovering your social network.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Sure
AUDIENCE: Now, into the
future, into the past.
What are you [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Well, yeah.
I didn't talk about that
because it's kind of hopeless.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Traffic
analysis is very, very
difficult to defend against.
It's so difficult
to defend against it
that I usually don't even try.
I mean, look,
there's some things
that I'm doing in Silent Phone
that defend against slightly
less capable opponents.
For example, if you're trying
to protect against traffic
analysis from an intel agency in
a particular country you happen
to be standing in
holding your device,
I mean, I do protect
against the traffic analysis
that he's doing by observing
the traffic between your phone
and our servers.
But if it's a worldwide
intelligency with global reach,
and they can see all
the traffic everywhere,
then it's nearly impossible
to protect against traffic
analysis in practical terms.
I mean, theoretically,
you could just
flood the entire internet
with dummy traffic
and try to use the needle
in a haystack approach.
But that's like draining the
oceans to find the submarine.
That's just not practical.
So traffic analysis--
you would be
surprised at what
traffic analysis can do.
I mean, for example,
most people don't even
consider some aspects
of traffic analysis.
For example, if you use a codec
that is variable bit rate,
you know, that some phonemes
produce different numbers
of bits than other
phonemes, that could
be used in traffic analysis.
Because even though the
payloads of the RTP packets
are encrypted, the
number of bits,
if you are using a
variable bit rate codec,
which I never use for this
reason, the number of bits
for each packet-- and it's
50 packets per second--
you could construct a
histogram of packet lengths
and match it to phrases,
words, phrases, and figure
out what people are
saying without actually
being able to break
the encryption just
from the packet.
So never use variable
bit rate codecs.
But that is a form
of traffic analysis.
So it's not just looking at
where the packets are going.
It's even studying
things like that.
There's all kinds of traffic.
And traffic analysis is an
extremely powerful field
of study and very difficult
to protect against.
So you know, I do
what I'm able to do.
I mean, it's like the guy
looking for his contact lens.
You see him searching on the
ground for his contact lens.
And you say, what
are you looking for?
I dropped my contact lens.
Well, where did you drop it?
Oh, across the
street over there.
Well, why are you
looking over here?
Well, because the
light's better.
I know how to do certain things.
So I'm just doing
what I know how to do.
But we need more than that.
But just being able to
protect the content,
even there, you
just have to protect
against your own servers
being compromised.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: All right, I'd
like to get a bit of context.
So the whole problem
of session set up
and key exchange is basically
a problem of short identifiers
versus longer identifiers.
Short, because we
remember facebook.com,
but we don't remember
the public key.
Personally, coming from a
bit of a bitcoin background,
I found it very practical to
exchange long identifiers,
especially with elliptic curves
having very short key material.
Just hold the [INAUDIBLE]
code and be done
and don't have to worry
about any of that problem.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
Silent Phone deals
with the problem,
to call a lengthy phone
number, and then I
have to do the exchange?
Or is there a way for
me to directly give you
a long identifier and
completely sidestep the problem?
Of course, then, that
probably doesn't change.
Because you [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN:
Yeah, I can tell you
that the human readable
identifier-- first,
it's provided in the
signaling, which is not
protected cryptographically.
Well, it is protected
cryptographically
in that it goes
through a TLS tunnel.
But if the server
is evil, then it's
only [INAUDIBLE] safe there.
But you have the ability to
edit the human readable name.
So if somebody calls you and
says that they're Barack Obama,
and you know they're
not Barack Obama,
you could edit that
and say, no he isn't.
It pre-fills the
string saying this call
appears to be from Barack Obama.
You can say, no it's not.
It's whatever the
name of the person
is who you're talking to.
Or you can say I'm not even
going to authenticate it.
Another thing that I do--
we do text messaging.
And we use the double ratchet
construct that Axolotl uses.
But I don't like the fact that
the double ratchet-- and this
is what they used in WhatsApp.
I don't like the fact that that
relies on long term identity
thieves.
And so what I do-- if
a product has both text
messaging and secure
VoIP, so I've got ZRTP.
GP
And because the ZRTP
security association
is established by this
voice authentication
of the short
authentication string,
I use that to reinforce the text
messaging security association
by sending the
long term identity
key under the protection
of the ZRTP exchange.
And that way, if you do
the verbal comparison
of the authentication
string, you now
have verified that
the text messaging
protocol is end to end secure
with no man in the middle.
So in other words, you bound
the long term identity key
to the same identity that you
did the ZRTP exchange with.
So if you have a
protocol that you like,
that you trust-- because
the ZRTP exchange
is very well optimized
just for voice.
Don't ever try to
use it for e-mail.
Back when I first got into
secure VoIP, some people said,
well can you use PGP
to do secure VoIP?
No, you can't.
PGP is for e-mail
and file encryption.
You've got to use
different protocols
for different problems
you're trying to solve.
And ZRTP is just to solve
the one problem of how do you
get to people to talk
to each other securely
with their voices
and with video?
Well, if you can do that, and
you get a really good security
association, you can
leverage that to reinforce
another security association
under another protocol
like Axolotl.
And that's what we
did in Silent Phone.
And so we don't have to
worry about the server
giving out fake long term
identity keys for the text
messaging protocol.
Because we protect it with ZRTP.
So anyway, yes?
SPEAKER 1: So we have time for
maybe one or two questions.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Do we
really have to cut this off?
It's at the end
of the day, right?
Have people started
moving toward the exits?
SPEAKER 1: If you'd like to
join us for the TGIF drinks,
then maybe people can
approach you then.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: OK, all right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: My question
is addressed to you
as a political activist.
I put it also on the Dory.
Maybe I'm playing here a
bit of devil's advocate.
But clearly, you strive
for better security,
better privacy.
And as you said, if the
server is compromised,
it's by some evil power.
But as a society,
after all, we have
these democratic societies.
We have entrusted the government
with power to survey after all.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So how do
we strike the balance?
I mean, this is mostly
legal concept, of course.
But how do we strike
it technically?
Maybe we do one after all.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah, sure.
It's the core question
that was at the center
of the crypto wars of
the 1990s and the one
that we keep on
running into today.
I mean, we now see a resurgence
of the crypto wars of the '90s.
It's come back again.
If we had-- always
had a government
that was wise and
true and fair and what
we want in a government,
then maybe that
would be a good trade to make.
You know?
But if all it takes is a court
order to use a back door,
then the United
States government
is not the only government
in the world that has courts,
or the Swiss government.
You know?
What about the North Koreans?
They have courts.
The Iranians?
China, Russia, they have courts.
I mean, just because
it's a court order,
doesn't mean that you're safe.
A few years ago, you guys-- I
don't know how many of you--
everybody's so young.
Maybe you didn't work here then.
But Google had a big
confrontation with China
because Google had
built back doors
into their servers for
law enforcement purposes.
And the Chinese hijacked
those back doors
to spy on Chinese dissidents.
And this resulted
in a confrontation
between Google and China.
And if you build in
back doors because you
think it's only going to be used
for the aforementioned utopian
wise, true philosopher
king government,
then you're going to find
that the back door can also
be used by not so nice people.
So Silent Phone is
used by Navy SEALs.
And they use it to go kill
Bin Laden or something,
whatever they're doing.
They're using it to
kill bad guys, right?
And they're not going to use
it if it has a back door.
So if you're worried
about Islamic extremism,
and you think, OK
well, we've got
to have some way to
get into this in case
Islamic extremists use it,
well, if you put a back door
in for that purpose, you're
also undermining the guys
that kill Islamic extremists.
So you've got to make the
best protections you can
and try to find some other way
of dealing with the problem.
Law enforcement is now in a
golden age of surveillance.
When you compare
what they have now
with what they had
20 years ago when
we were fighting the
crypto wars in the 1990s,
they have it so much better now.
They have OCR to scan the
license plates of cars
from traffic cameras so they
can see all the cars traveling
everywhere.
They know where
everybody is going
with their cars because
of traffic cameras
reading license plates.
They have face
recognition software
that can look through a
camera on a city street
and see thousands
of people walking by
and identify every one
of them, or most of them,
depending on how far away
they are from the camera.
And they can see where people
are walking even without cars.
They have transactional data
from where you eat lunch
with a credit card.
Or they can see you
walking in the restaurant.
They know who you
had lunch with.
They can see a hotel
and see everybody
going in and out of the hotel.
So they know which mistresses
the politicians are sleeping
with that they're
not married to so
that those politicians,
opposition politicians,
can be neutralized
by the incumbency.
They actually do that in Russia.
I mean, there was a
prosecutor in Russia
that was investigating
corruption.
And he was neutralized by
putting him in a sex scandal
and getting him out of that.
You have to recognize that
today's pervasive surveillance
environment is so much
more powerful, so much more
complete and sweeping and
breathtaking in its scope,
that law enforcement has it like
they've never had it before.
And they're complaining
about going dark.
What that means,
really, is that there's
a few black pixels in
this vast 4K display
of a big picture they now have.
And they've got a few
tiny little black pixels
that are dark.
They're not going dark.
They have a couple
of missing pixels.
And for them to
demand that we hand
over those last few pixels,
it's going to hurt everybody.
And it's going to make it
impossible to have any kind
of political opposition.
You think that it's
safe to set it up
because maybe it's OK to have a
government to have surveillance
capability.
But what happens
in a democracy when
you elect someone that is an
absolute nightmare to elect?
[LAUGHTER]
Then it's the end of
the American experiment.
AUDIENCE: Point well made.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Unfortunately, we
have to stop here,
at least so that my colleagues
can close the meeting.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: We'll be around.
PHIL ZIMMERMANN: OK, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And a lot of people
are more curious about it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]